okay I'll get started what I'm talking
about is a topic of spectral Zita
functions and is that that won't be big
enough for people at the bags I think so
let me large that this is the abstract
it got truncated on the website because
it couldn't handle symbols so the basic
idea is that if you have an operator a
and you can compute the eigenvalues and
they form a discrete set well you can
define something called the spectral
Zita function which in those cases is
just a sum over the eigenvalues raised
reciprocal of the eigenvalues to the
power of s and this is the number of
papers Barry al azhar they and Crandall
and both Crandall and Barry I know to be
Mathematica users I don't know about al
azhari pretty probably is too so its
long-term connection now what struck by
interest in looking at this there's a
paper below nyan Robinette so 2009 Paper
Chase is a constraints on aerie function
zeroes from quantum mechanical some
rules and I'm not going to go through
the paper obviously but basically
they're they're solving a differential
equation computing the eigenvalues of
this differential equation it's an airy
function is the solution they go through
some complicated manipulations and they
find that there are certain properties
relating the sums of the eigenvalues for
their system so essentially they're
solving the Schrodinger equation with a
linear potential over half plane now I'm
not going to go through it just to
except to say that it takes them five or
six pages before they go through various
mechanics manipulations and eventually
they produce late in the paper
a table of identities and here's this
table where they find certain sums I'm
going to define these but I'm going to
show that this is a one-line Mathematica
command so it probably shouldn't have
been published as a paper I think that's
that that's the bottom line point I want
to make and I was intrigued when I
looked at this to see you know what they
were doing and why what I realized was
there something that they didn't know
and I have to admit as an undergraduate
I didn't know either but I let me just
go back into my presentation I should
have closed a few things down but let's
go back into it so what they were
computing was a set of some rules where
are the eigenvalues of this operator so
let me just get into the material here
so let's first look at the functions
which they which are we're dealing with
here their Airy functions of course
they're built in Mathematica there's
some nice applications of them in Dell
and F and this book of lan-sui eyes so
if we plot do a contour plot of the
absolute value of the error function we
can see it has roots along the negative
real axis that's one type of error
function the second type of error
functions more interesting because it
has roots along the negative real axis
as well as these two other branches or
we can do a complex phase plot of one
over airy to see the roots of the
function quite clearly along the
negative real axis here and see the
overall structure of the function so
let's do the derivation and it's
absolutely straight forward if you start
with the Schrodinger equation I always
work in dimensionless forms getting rid
of all the constants you can always put
them back in later so I don't understand
why so many physicists include H bars at
everything when you can get them back in
and it just makes everything more
complicated leaving them in the
equations in the first place but you
start with the equation and you want to
apply the boundary conditions now i
notice that diesel has been enhanced but
you still can't hand
directly as far as I could see anyway
the the second of those boundary
conditions directly you have to take a
limit or a series expansion to do that
so but the first point is if you my
first thing is I tend to I don't know
how many people use aware of this
notation but with in Mathematica there
is a map notation for pure functions and
you will see it occasionally when you do
a dissolve you'll see this map notation
coming up and instead of hashes and
ampersands I prefer to use the
mathematical notation which jason Herod
Harrison out of then so we can define
the Schrodinger operator as an operator
L with a variable X which is a map
between F and negative DV DX double
second derivative F plus the linear term
this is the potential term and we can
ask Mathematica to solve that when we
get realizes and I can't easily scroll
here so let me just probably just go on
and fifty percent up that will be way
too small I realize that people but
another feature that I do like is that
if you mouse over these it identifies
i'm using traditional form but it
identifies that this is the area I and
the area bi function with two obviously
to undetermined coefficients if we apply
if we compute the asymptotic series of
this and I'll enlarge that because it'll
be too small again if we compute the
asymptotic series for the Aerie function
about infinity we see that it's got a
decaying exponential term but if we do
the the one for bi we have a divergent
exponential behavior so we require c2 to
be 0 and that's one of the boundary
conditions applied and then to apply the
other one we do a Taylor series of the
error function about 0 and I don't know
how many people use this but you just
add an order term to a function it
doesn't work for some types of series
but it certainly
x4 Taylor series and we get this first
term our linear term and so on but if
we're requiring the function to be zero
what we are requiring is that a I of
negative e which is our energy
eigenvalue has to vanish so what we're
interested in is the zeros of zeros of
the airy function and the the nice thing
for us is that those zeros are built in
so we have the energy eigenvalues en is
the negative ani ends the standard
notation that is used for this thing so
a couple of things we can do the first
of those is we can tell that this may
not be best practice but it's
interesting we just say a I of whenever
it sees that pattern is zero so we'll
we're automatically applying those rules
we can just check that that works so we
can also do something that it's not I
don't know if it's still documented n
values so this is possibly a bad idea
but it still works instead of defining a
n to be a numerical value you can define
the numerical value of a n so I'm just
saying the numerical value of a n is the
numerical value of the built-in thing
and if I want to do this to high
precision I can do this and I'm also
using I'm saving the values when I
compute them so because these
particularly high precision values if I
want to compute 500 of these it takes a
while I might as well save and compute
them so once I have once I've done that
and we just check not sure so I've just
executed those are what we then can look
at again because I lose scrolling in
this mode what is the numerical value of
a1 what is it 240 decimal places so so i
can compute and store these zeros and so
now if we visualize the function along
the real axis we get the zeros showing
up on the function i'm hiding the code
but you know I you know this is for its
just there it's a simple plot command so
we know where the zeros are we now know
what the iden functions are but to
normalize the eigenfunctions we have to
compute the integral of the function and
we can do that and that's a and it gets
a nice simple result because I've told
it that the area of a n is zero it knows
about the roots and now we can define
the normalized eigen functions and again
i'm defining the normal eigen normalized
eigen functions using the map notation
it's I think it's nicer and once we have
these two things we define the
normalized eigen functions we now can
plot them and just see what they look
like and this is the behavior we see
that here this line here is our linear
potential the ground state first excited
state second excited state and in these
are units the energies which turn out
just to be the negative of the roots of
the erie functions and one thing of
course that crossing point is the
inflection point of the curve or an
inflection point of the curve which you
can see so we've got the eigenfunctions
well now a bit of maths and this is the
maths that Robinette bolonia were
missing and that the mass that they're
missing is the weierstrass factorization
theorem which I have to admit I don't
know what the situation is in American
universities but it wasn't taught to me
as an undergraduate and I only
encountered several years later and we
did complex function theory but we
didn't get as far as the weierstrass
factorization urine what it what it is
it's essentially a way of writing
special function analytic functions as
products is one way of thinking about
this so the theorem is stated there I'm
not going to go into the details and I'm
no expert on it but that the key is this
this result that says if you have a
function with simple zeroes you can
write it as a product and there are more
general cases here but you can write as
a product which involves the value of
the function at 0
a simple exponential factor and an
infinite product and I think it's clear
that this term in the product whenever Z
is equal to a n that term in the product
vanishes so this function vanishes at
the roots of the whatever function you
are trying to do so it's the
generalization of writing a polynomial
in terms of the roots of a polynomial as
a sensual case of course you need
there's convergence conditions how to
handle other cases and there's
generalizations of this and some very
nice ones but I don't have time to cover
those so just as a very simple example
the weierstrass product for the one over
the gamma function the roots of one over
the gamma function are the negative
integers and zero and so if you check
this you just get a true that it's
exactly of that form that we have there
so the gamma function is a nice simple
example of that well the realization is
that the airy function is also exactly
of that form you can just write a
download by hand it's hard to find that
formula and I couldn't actually there
was one paper i found that actual
formula and I soon would be a number of
russian books that have it but in the
Western literature it's really hard to
find that explicitly stated but it's
obvious I mean it's just an application
of the weierstrass theorem so again as
you can see this bit will vanish at the
Ares eros now however if you define the
partial products of that just to see
what it looks like and you try and
visualize it that's with five terms in
the product this is with a hundred terms
in that product its convergence is
rather slow it works but it's it's a
slowly convergent thing but you take the
product to infinity and it does converge
to the function so the process that we
want to do is to work out the sort of
sums that are involved is involved in
something that is essentially obvious
that if you want to convert a product
into a sum you take the logarithmic
derivative of it and we can take the
logarithmic derivative of the error
function
it's just that which is sort of obvious
but we can also compute the logarithmic
derivative of the infinite product and
I'm taking just the front terms there
which is nice and simple and if we take
the rest of it we just get accommodation
terms now I've admitted the infinite
product symbol here but there's an
infinite and implied infinite sum so I'm
just taking a generic term in the
product it's much more efficient to do
that as long as you keep track of what's
going on I just need to take an infinite
sum over these and so the conclusion is
this that the Aerie the logarithmic
derivative the area function minus its
value at 0 is just equal to this sum
which is essentially well I haven't seen
other people say it this way but I
believe that's just the metal F'lar
decomposition of the function but this
can be expanded in a power series in Z
and if you do so what the the
coefficients of that turn out to be
these are easy to functions it's just
the recipient of the power series
expansion you can check that so you get
the air easy to function and that turns
out to be analytic for as long as the
real part of s is greater than three
hearts and so some some properties this
have been studied okay moving on if you
define alfa-2b this ratio of these two
terms which turns out to be it can be
expressed in closed form in terms of
gamma functions you do that you can do
the series expansion of both sides of
this so this is the left hand side this
bit here is the right hand side i'm
using the fact that alpha is related to
these gamma functions and if i do this
the series is immediate and you get this
the air easy two functions at the
integers greater than or equal to two
are all just simple polynomials in the
ratio nice and simple and elegant is
very easy to to get that result so
well what air baloney and Robin nope
we're looking at these products and that
equations that I showed earlier
essentially this series of results so
this is the difference between two Airy
zeros and your interest in this infinite
sum and they found these interesting
combinations which they were surprised
by but i'll just show you that it's
essentially a trivial result that if you
take the piece derivative of the
logarithmic derivative function and you
subtract off one of the terms in the sum
then just by interchanging the
differentiation the summation you get
the peace derivative of Z minus a in the
denominator and so their sums which they
are after I just taken the limit as that
approach as one of the roots of this and
what you get is it can be expressed in
closed form and if you look at this
we've basically like the peace
derivative of this function evaluated at
Point and the bottom line that we get is
this that on the left-hand side we have
this logarithmic derivative the area
with one of the polls taken out and it
it generates all of their sums for them
so my point is that's a one line command
for generating every one of their sums
it's the whole paper that they
essentially achieved so if you to put
that in context if you do this series
expansion which is one line command you
can extract all of those escapees out of
it in a light it's two lines are two
lines of code but essentially that's all
of them there so it's generated directly
from the air easy to function expansion
so well you know just to be sure that
i'm not completely making a mess here if
you do this numerically or you do it
directly the the second power that's
this column here i should have been a
bit sloppy where I put my ends there
second column there is slowly converging
but as you go to higher and higher
powers like the fifth power you get very
nice convergence to the result and I'm
taking 500 terms in the Sun just to
check that it's it's correct so it works
so my conclusions is well sums over
roots undo that sums over the roots can
be easily computed the keys the
weierstrass product theorem which should
be well known but isn't as well known as
it should be by physicists using log
derivative to convert products in
twosomes the key point of this analysis
if you think about it ideas for the area
function but clearly this works for any
function has a product definition so
there's nothing special about this and
all those quantum some rules applied to
one particular function were not
required and they also treat a number of
multiple sums and if you take products
of those sorts of results and expand
them out you get all these more
complicated identities and they're just
following in from taylor series applied
to it so that's all i wanted to say